hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israelis
und tobias matt natürlich heute machen
wir eine genau häuser vom iran
geburtstag und setzt eine monster hatte
gewünscht vor kurzem habe ich sie ja
auch als dracula geschminkt oder ja umso
mehr da hat sich bei mir hat sich die
torte gewünscht und wir haben sie so ein
bisschen eben an die serie monster high
chorin haben uns daran orientiert und
haben hier das logo davor noch den
schriftzug sanierer in der original
schrift natürlich unternährer hat sich
eine erdbeertorte gewünscht die ist hier
unten drin und eine schokotorte dies da
oben kann ja mal sechs jahre alt
geworden und zur vorbereitung habe ich
bereits gestern hielt diese figuren und
die schleife zum beispiel vorbereitet
dann konnte das alles gut durchtrocknen
und heute habe ich dann nicht von hinten
himmlisch sind nie so schön wenn wir
verliebt er nicht seinen boden
ja und heute mit einem prinzip nur noch
alles gefüllt und dekoriert und werden
uns gleich auf den weg machen denn wir
feiern heute im parlament noch alle
einladen
nein zum glück ist bis dahin schon ein
paar wochen her
also ich habe zuerst meine figuren
hergestellt und zeige euch wie und ich
bin gerade voll erkennt und euch glaubt
man habe los geht's ich starte mit der
modellierung des monster high logos und
verwendet dafür schwarze modelle
schokolade und rolle sie nach dem kneten
auf 5 mm stärke aus und das geht am
besten mit hilfe von teig eltern dafür
habe ich mir jetzt eine schablone
ausgeschnitten die habe ich aus dem
internet einfach heruntergeladen und
schneidet damit die modelle schokolade
mit einem körper aus
jetzt rolle ich blüten passte in weiß
pink und schwarz ganz schön aus und
schneidet damit die einzelteile wie
gesicht schleife und augen aus und dafür
könnt ihr die schablone dann im einzel
teile schneiden und diese dann zum
ausschneiden für die bögen passte
verwenden und die blüten passe die
trocknet sehr schnell aus und daher
eignet sie sich für die vielen
dekorationen sehr gut
die deko teilen lässt sich jetzt kurz
antrocknen damit diese später besser
ankleben können ich gebe jetzt noch zwei
schachspieler in angetrockneten
aufsteller aus modelle schokolade damit
ich ihn später besser in die torte
stecken kann
die angetrockneten einzelteile klebe ich
dann mit einem essbaren kleber auf und
diesen streiche ich ganz schön mit einem
pinsel auf den aufsteller lasse ich dann
ganz durch trocknen
als nächstes schneide ich jetzt den
namen aus und dafür habe ich die blüten
passt in ausgerollt und für den
originalen monster high schriftzug habe
ich mir eine vorlage im internet
angeschaut und den dann freihand
ausgeschnitten aber falls sich das zu
schwer ist dann könnt ihr euch auch die
schablone machen aus pappe oder auf
papier
die einzelnen buchstaben klebe ich dann
auf einen dünnen weißen streifen blüten
passte und schneide mit einem kater
drumherum
und jetzt stelle ich noch aus den resten
kleine und große herzchen und sterne aus
aus an getrocknete blüten passte
schneidig die zahl sechs aufklebt sie
dann auf einen schwarz stück blüten
passte und schneidet dann die ziffer mit
einem schwarzen rand zu recht
aus modelle starrte vor mich jetzt noch
eine schleife und dafür werden zwei
längliche rechtecke an einem in damit
etwas kleber gestrichen
dann lege ich ein kleines
zusammengerollt das stück küchenpapier
dazwischen und klebt die rechtecke
jeweils zu einer schlaufe zusammen
und die zwei klebe ich in der mitte
zusammen und form aus einem weiteren
rechteck das mittelstück und es wird an
vorne befestigt und auf der rückseite
der schleife verbunden
die figuren sind jetzt alle gut
durchgetrocknet und jetzt kann euch die
torte bereits film ich habe jetzt hier
was vorbereitet und zwar einen hellen
großen kuchen des 26 cm groß und einen
kleinen schokokuchen als 20 cm groß und
es sind beides die lockeren kuchenteig
für motiv torten also auch sehr saftig
und die schneide ich jetzt mit orten
säge erst mal durch
jetzt kann ich die torte füllen und zwar
hat sich samira einmal eine vanillecreme
gewünscht das ist jetzt eine
französische buttercreme unterstreiche
ich jetzt ein bisschen rauf auf die
karten backe damit ist der kuchenteig
gleich schön angeben kann selbst sich
den ersten bogen
da ich jetzt ein bisschen französische
buttercreme drauf
jetzt kommt eine lage etwa frucht
einlage rein und das ganze habe ich zwei
mal gemacht dass die torte wird dann so
auch fertig gefüllt
die torte kann jetzt erstmal in den
kühlschrank für eine halbe stunde danach
werde ich sie auch mit der buttercreme
komplett glatt streichen und mit wandern
überziehen oder in der zeit kann ich
jetzt schon mal die schokotorte mit
einer schokoladen gerne streiche
bei der schokoladen torte also ich mag
bitter schokolade aber solide hat sich
doch vollmilchschokolade gewünscht
deswegen habe ich dieses mal eine
freundin gianna
und auch diese torte werde ich jetzt
kurz kühl stellen bis ich sehe da gar
streichen kann und kann jetzt aber schon
mal das skateboard mit etwas von dort
über 10
jetzt habe ich hier ein kickboard das
ist 35 cm gross möchte es nämlich schön
dekorieren damit man es auch ganz gut
sieht und habe etwas pinkfarbenen
fondant den hand mit lebensmittelfarbe
ein bisschen eingefärbt besser und dann
rolle ich jetzt tun aus und klebt dann
mit etwas erst machen kleber auf die
kate klasse also auch scanner
jetzt habe ich hier ein bisschen
schwarze tüten pass der ganze bühne
ausgerollt blüten passte deswegen weil
ich sie eben richtig schön ausschauen
kann ohne dass sie schnell zerreißt und
da werde ich jetzt kleinen streifen zu
schneiden damit das aussieht wie sie ja
wir sind zebramuster
und die einzelnen streifen werden jetzt
aufgeklärt mit der tiefe es waren kleber
und zwar so dass sie immer zur mitte hin
zeigen also da muss man darauf achten
damit später einfach ein schönes
gesamtbild ergibt
ich kenne ich die torte fertigt
dekorieren die kleine torte werde ich
hellblau und die große torte mit
schwarzem von dort übersehen
jetzt geht es mit der unteren torte
weiter
ich habe jetzt im umfang wird orte
einmal ausgewiesen mit einem maßband und
80 cm und jetzt mache ich wie so eine
art kissen in unserem stück muster mit
rein mit dem geodreieck geht es am
besten
und zwar setze ich jetzt hier einmal
einen punkt an gehen dann von darf fünf
zentimeter weiter und ich rechne es
deswegen aus dass ich einfach weiß wie
ich die abstände machen muss damit vorne
und henkel eben auch fast jetzt werde
ich alle fünf zentimeter immer eine
kleine markierung machen
jetzt sehen wir dass geodreieck und
setzt es jetzt so hohmann
das heißt im 45 grad winkel und setzt es
hier vorne an
an der ersten markierung und fahrt jetzt
hier mit einem modellwechsel so ein
bisschen der linie macht
und jetzt hatte ich ja das lineal die
ganze zeit so hoch angesetzt und jetzt
werde ich all bringen und ist so rum
ansetzen und die linien auch noch mal in
die andere richtung machen
jetzt kann ich die torte auf skateboard
draufsetzen und es gebe ich jetzt so ein
bisschen an
und hier überall wo diese schnittstellen
sind also das kleine kreuz werde ich
jetzt jeweils eine kleine perle
reinsetzen und dafür nehmt ihr am besten
einen pinsel macht ein kleines loch
hinein dann kommt da ein bisschen kleber
rein und dann kann die kellerei gesetzt
werden sobald etwa aufgestellt
wie kann ich die zwei torten
zusammensitzen und damit die obere torte
jetzt nicht ein sagt in die untere werde
ich jetzt hier ein paar cake pops ticks
befestigen und die auf die richtige
länge zuschneiden
und damit die torte später beim
transport nicht nur rutscht mit ein
bisschen ganache fest
jetzt kann ich hier oben die einzelnen
elemente dran kleben das heißt die
herzchen und die sterne dann werde ich
ein bisschen aus bäckerin mit
lebensmittel farbstiften und hier unten
kommt noch eine kleine bord übertragen
für die schleife
man möchte kann man die einzelnen teile
noch mit etwas gold bruder oder silber
bruder zum beispiel ein bisschen
bepinseln damit wir einfach ein bisschen
und zum abschluss fehlt noch hier unten
eine bordüre und die macht jetzt mit
meinem von landwirte lehrer und zwar
kommt da vorne eine scheibe rein dann
nämlich dieses mal diese scheibe
und jetzt habe ich schon ein stück
schwarzen fondant weich geknetet und der
kommt jetzt hier oben rein und dann kann
ich die kurbel drehen
genausowenig wir kleben jetzt hier noch
ein paar herzchen drauf die passenden
job täglich 68 us-dollar solchen ich auf
meine und dann zimmer im prinzip fertig
und jetzt müssen uns auch beeilen denn
die geburtstags also deine gäste kommen
wir sind jetzt mit der torte fertig und
müssen uns jetzt auch gleich auf den weg
machen denn deine gäste kommen jetzt
gleich und wir können deswegen die torte
und natürlich nicht anschreiben aber wir
werden sie gleich auf der feier
abschneiden
ja auf jeden fall hat es uns sehr viel
spaß gemacht von mira hat mir gestern
schon ein bisschen bei der vorbereitung
geholfen und wir hoffen dass ihr die
torte mal nach macht wenn ja dann
postete ein foto auf installieren oder
auf facebook ich halt auch zu reden ich
glaube das habe ich gleich keine stimme
mehr willst du noch was sagen
diesmal gehen wir los als da also bis
zum nächsten mal
und das rezept gibt es auf bis zum
nächsten mal
und der papa rot ist wirklich
transportboxen und wird sie auch gut
transportieren können